she is the senator from Minnesota who's
running for the Democratic nomination
for president she had a very good week
Amy Klobuchar
[Applause]
yes I'm ready to come to Cal gonna say
well sure that's where the money is
votes the votes well that the states in
the bag we don't care about this day
it's a Super Tuesday State Oh for the
nomination yeah I'm thinking about I'm
sorry
crazy me but hey you got the real time
bounce
yes Your Honor I don't know if I was you
I would say being myself I've been
waiting my whole life to hear the word
surging next to my name
you are surging do you like surging and
why are you why are you searching it's
much better than not search yeah and I
think it is because for me as you know I
didn't have the biggest bank account
I still don't I'm not the loudest voice
not the tallest one and despite the
Bloomberg back and forth with the
president where the president claimed he
was five foot four I am the only one
that is truly five foot four foot four
exactly yeah there is a president that
was five foot four yes that's referral
so but I think for me what it is is one
I've got the receipts I've made the case
that I am the one that has repeatedly
led a ticket and won and brought in
moderate Republicans independents as
well as a fired-up Democratic base I've
done that repeatedly that's what we want
to win big again I admire anybody who
can get up every day and say the same
line no no I know I'm glad you're doing
it I'm just saying I admire it okay
buddy must be grueling it must be like
Groundhog Day
you have to know of course you got
updated into your head some people say
the lines I've actually lived I know is
a difference and then the second thing
is that I think in the debate that gave
me the opportunity to have one heatedly
show I'm tough enough to take on the
president and to make the case that this
is also about having someone they can
put themselves in the shoes of the
regular people in this country because
this president has no empathy well okay
but then then why do 83% of farmers now
you know farmers you're from Minnesota
they have farmers sure every bite of
farmers work yeah in the country
frigging New Jersey as far everybody's
got farmers okay farm state okay so why
do 83% of farmers say they're for Trump
well that's where they may be in the
past I don't think that's where they're
gonna be in 2016 and no 2020 and but
where they were in 2016 I don't think
it's gonna be where they are in 2020 and
let me make the case there's been a 25%
increase in farm bankruptcies it's not
just the farmers it's the world so why
don't that why isn't that's the point
why isn't that reflected in the number
of farmers who are AG in him oh because
they have to have a candidate running
against him that does not see the
Midwest is why over country and I'm
gonna be able to say to him on the
debate stage farm brain crop seeds up 25
percent you're not doing anything on
child care in the rural areas or child
poverty and you are treating the people
in the middle of the country like they
are poker chips and one of your bankrupt
casino
with all due respect for me they're my
friends our neighbors with all due
respect Democrats have been pitching
that for a while and it doesn't work on
a lot of people who it should wear I
agree rationally that is the argument
I'm asking you why doesn't it sink in
well why not trust that let's think
about what happened in some of the races
around the country two congressional
seats in Iowa in 2018 here my proof
points right went to Democrats because
it was a check on Donald Trump it was an
economic check but it was also a decency
check a patriotism sure Laura Kelly is
now the governor of Kansas she beat Kris
Kobach Gretchen Whitmer is now the
governor of Michigan
look at those seats in Orange County
look where Jackie Rosen got elected in
Nevada we don't know these people
account but they won but see because the
people could relate to them I'm just
saying when you go herb Klein ermine and
the people like yeah that's why she's
inside DC because she thinks the people
in those states know exactly what I'm
talking about you can have Democrats
that bring people with them instead of
shutting them out as well as you we're
talking two swing states I'm good with
it
because you do have to get those states
right yeah okay so now here's the thing
with the Democratic Party and what we've
been hearing all week is Bernie Sanders
won in New Hampshire but the people in
the moderate Lane and I'm sure this
drives you crazy because it it lumps you
and people don't like to be lumped so
I'm sorry but the truth is that there's
all America likes our contests like our
sports there's got to be an American
Conference on a national conference so
we have a Super Bowl in the Democratic
Party it's the far left right the
progress whatever I want to call it and
then the moderate lane even though all
you moderates are quite progressive so
moderates together you got too many in
your lane you got you and Pete and Biden
and Bloomberg coming in and then
Bernie's all alone in that way yeah
they're all bees in a comes before be
but you know what I'm saying your lane
is actually winning but Bernie's winning
the actual battle because he's the only
one in his Lane when you combine the
moderates they're like two to one over
the far left what do you do about that
first of all Elizabeth's in his Lane and
secondly how much anymore okay they kind
of consolidate that used to have your
problem okay
so secondly this is a primary we've only
had two small stage Oh Nevada's next
then South Carolina then Super Tuesday
which includes California so you don't
want to winnow it down and just say hey
hey little people in the lane you go
away because we're gonna give it to the
billionaire's and the guy everyone knows
I don't think that's I think you have to
figure out when you look at who has won
in the past and let a ticket to victory
a peanut farmer in Georgia right Bill
Clinton a guy named Barack Obama right
people didn't think we're gonna win I
mean I just I think
make that decision based on these
dynamics right now you have to let the
people look at the candidates and make a
decision okay so how do you think Trump
if you're the candidate will attack you
because he's never attacked you to my
knowledge oh yes he has what does he say
oh no when I better get one you're
nobody unless you got a nickname when I
announced in the middle of that blizzard
in Minnesota with four inches of snow in
my head and talking about climate change
he quickly tweeted out this that making
fun of me for talking about climate
change in a blizzard which makes no
sense and then called me snow woman
which will give you a sense of how I'm
gonna deal with them because I think you
need humor to deal word guy I mean he
uses humor even though he's known one
bit funny I wrote back I said the
science is on my side Donald Trump and
I'd like to see how your hair would fare
in a blizzard
so that's what we have on our side
rapier wit sweets very enthusiastic
audiences and liberal cities here's what
he has military police announce rows in
the bikers
oh no so okay I'm gonna ask this
question because I asked you to bevery
democratic politician comes on here I
just want to make clear I have built the
coalition with a lot of groups okay that
aren't traditionally in our party and I
think if we bring them in in a big way
as well as our prior to base we win
that's not what I'm talking about okay
let's go I'm saying you win okay you
worried I'm glad that's different than
him leaving mm-hmm
that's what I want to know what is the
plan and I think we need to start
talking about it now because it's very
hard for me to imagine you winning the
popular the electoral vote fair and
square and him sending out a
congratulatory telegram great day so
glad you won we had a good match and let
me tell you where I keep the you know
important papers he's not leaving these
people are not going to give up power
what is the plan if he says I find the
regularities the people who ran it in
Iowa screwed it up again I have to stay
it was rigged he's already said this
many times what do you do then the first
thing you do is now you start now and
that is to win big which I believe will
help now just don't secondly come on you
win all these states in the country
sorry for him to say secondly you make
sure that we have backup paper ballots
you push for that's those are my bills
you do everything to protect our living
in the era of fake news okay and not
there's no facts anymore it's just about
power you have always had a peaceful
transition of power in this always have
had we have correct and we are now in a
different world you have the people on
your side and in a big way he has a lot
of people on his side the ones with the
guns
I think we'll do this I drink that the
law we hope or what we have to unite on
as a country is that the rule of law
cannot handle four more years of a guy
that thinks he's above it tomorrow will
you at least start asking the people in
power the police in the military what
would you do if he said he wouldn't
leave would you at least ask start
asking them get them on the record is
that every single Republican I've run
against in my entire career has left
politics for good great good luck
congratulations on your surge
[Applause]
you